I'm Laura Ingram and this is a special
edition of the Ingram angle from
Washington tonight
all right if it's Friday you know I'm
going to ask the question how low can he
go
as in Biden in those polls measuring his
job performance of course a new AP norc
poll has Biden's approval at 39 the
lowest of his presidency and among
Democrats his approval is at just 73
percent when for all of 2021 it never
dropped below 82. among Hispanics in a
new Quinnipiac poll he's at 26.
now a key takeaway from the AP piece is
that only two in 10 Americans say our
country is on the right track who are
the two
what's most striking are that some of
the comments from Americans about
Biden's performance they're stunning one
saying I don't know how much worse it
can get or he hasn't delivered on any of
the promises
his policies are destroying the economy
now one of the more charitable ones was
I think he's tired
of course all of these remarks are on
point Americans are not stupid they see
what's happening to the family budget
they feel it they know how bad the crime
is
they see food and bus tickets given to
the illegals as they debate themselves
even having a family vacation this
summer
and the overwhelming majority of
Americans tell Quinnipiac they're seeing
what we've been warning you about an
economic recession is just around the
corner
and finally
we wondered when this would start
happening Biden's boosters are even
seeing the writing on the wall
I am on on the more pessimistic end of
the Spectrum in terms of how I think the
economy is going to perform I think
inflation is going to force the FED to
raise interest rates certainly to five
six percent maybe hire me the road ahead
does not look great there's very little
to be optimistic about the three eyes
inflation immigration and now infant
formula pocketbook issues kitchen table
issues have been abstract for a long
time now suddenly they're very real
yes things are so bad that even
trump-hating liberals can't ignore the
situation any longer
and naturally things aren't any better
on the foreign policy front either
remember one of Biden's favorite lines
about his conversations with foreign
leaders
the message I want the world here today
America is back
America is back
diplomacy is back at the center of our
foreign policy well Biden's in Asia on
his first trip and I don't think any of
the world leaders he's meeting with are
very impressed America's Global
influence and power after all comes from
her strength both economic and Military
and both are now badly compromised
because of the policies and decisions
made by Biden and the Democrats
after a botched withdrawal a disgusting
withdrawal in Afghanistan now a
prolonged proxy war in Ukraine
that slow pivot to Asia and a rising
China
our allies and our adversaries see
America at it's adrift and can you blame
them
how does anyone expect our enemies to
fear us if so many of our own Elites
seem embarrassed by our history
disdainful of our founding and disgusted
frankly by our traditions
and Biden's White House has made their
discuss for America clear
we know we have work to do at home
that includes addressing profound
inequities including systemic racism
racism is real in America
and it has always been racism
the ugly poison in his long haunted and
plagued our nation in the end you just
can't govern very well a country you
fundamentally loathe you can only rule
over it
if Biden's puppeteers were pulling the
strings right now putting all those
words in the teleprompter if they really
loved America I mean really loved her
they wouldn't be doing any of this
they wouldn't have waved off Larry
Summers on the inflation issue a year
ago they wouldn't have put us deeper in
debt with covet and stupid buildback
better spending
they certainly wouldn't have killed our
energy Independence
and they wouldn't be turning American
against American on race
they wouldn't have let our borders go to
the cartels
they wouldn't have set in motion the
policies that are causing so much pain
and suffering to those who deserve it
least hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else